this morning we're taking a look at
Louisville Kentucky to see how national
issues are playing out on the local
level
it's our continuing series American
Voices the city's Democratic Mayor Greg
Fischer has been called the most
innovative mayor in the country
Louisville has added more than 63
thousand jobs since he took office in
2011 mayor Fischer is also working to
increase the number of college graduates
in the city and creating new job
training programs he joins us at the
table good morning there good to be with
you good to have you here let's talk
about what happened in Charlottesville
over the weekend because I know you
wrote about it and you said this is not
the country we aspire to be well that's
right I mean Louisville is the home of
Muhammad Ali it was about a year ago
when we laid him to rest and you saw the
whole world come together to celebrate
this great man
values of compassion confidence
spirituality that's the United States of
America it's not what we saw in
Charlottesville over the weekend so we
condemned that type of activity that
this is an easy one for all leaders to
get up and say this is not us the
strength of America is our human values
that's what we should be celebrating
every day diversity is what makes us
strong no you go it's happening a number
of spots I mean you move the Confederate
monument last year there the statue of a
Confederate soldier in Louisville was
vandalized last night's do you plan to
move more monuments and more statues
there was a big monument about 75 feet
tall that we had a peaceful discussion
about in our city we moved it to another
location we didn't destroy it it is an
important part of history but it needs
to be in the proper context there's
another one of a man on a horse not in
the Confederate uniform what I called
for yesterday was to identify any piece
of public art that had any potential
connotation of slavery or racism to it
so we could discuss each and every one
of them and put them in their proper
context people say that mayors are where
the rubber meets the ground yeah what
kinds of issues do you think are looming
in the future for America's cities well
the biggest issue in the cities in the
countryside in all of America is social
mobility jobs what's happening to our
middle class right now it's being
hollowed out that's one of the reasons
why you see some of this hatred that's
coming down the streets people don't
know the fear they don't feel connected
they don't feel hope they
know where they fit in a rapidly
changing global economy so they don't
know what to do we need major system
changes that involve everybody so they
can have a hopeful path to the future
that's a rather popular ISM well AB
Debray need to fight against that they
have to brexit after what happened here
in our country so what we need to do is
say how can everybody participate
meaningfully in a job that has a future
to it where you can have dignity of work
and support your family one of the
things you're doing is bringing
manufacturing to Louisville how are you
doing that or a great manufacturing of
about a hundred thousand jobs simple all
of our jobs we want to focus on
globalization and innovation that's
where the action is so whether it's
manufacturing or its Bourbon ISM whether
it's wellness and aging care you have
those two elements you've got good jobs
about the opioid crisis because that's
something mayor's I think are
confronting really on the front lines is
the Trump administration doing enough
well what's important is we've got
realized how fast this is hitting our
country over the last two or three years
the spread of opioids is a real epidemic
in rural areas in urban areas it's
something that we should all be able to
come together for in our health care
plans it needs to be covered mental
illness stigma it needs to go away
so to make this a national emergency is
the right thing to do because it's
eating up some of our rural areas and
our city as well you've used the word
interesting compassion how do you make
the Louisville a more compassionate City
how do you define compassion in terms of
a city well three big values for
Louisville lifelong learning health and
compassion and compassion means respect
for each and every one of our citizens
so that their human potential is
flourishing thriving shining like the
Sun is what Thomas Merton said so the
Dalai Lama is a strategic partner of our
city because of our efforts in
compassion when you look across America
in terms of state legislators in terms
of mayors there are more Republicans and
Democrats what does the Democratic Party
have to do to regain its political
momentum well you got to take care of
business I mean that's what mayor's do
every day cities are the home of 85
percent of our population over 90
percent of our GDP we don't see blue we
don't see red we see opera so how do you
speak to income inequality how do you
speak to the kind of issues that are
causing people to be fearful and
therefore turn to
a range of kinds of things they're not
in their own best interest well you take
it directly on in the workplace to ask
ourselves what's happening to these jobs
and what can we do as leaders to make
sure that there are jobs that have good
solid middle-class wages to them the way
we're doing it right now we're just a
few people are really winning a lot of
people are losing is not the solution
interesting you say you don't see red
you don't see blue I mean you're you
have a you're a Democratic mayor in a
state a Republican governor Republican
state has two very famous Republican
senators how do you maintain that that
job with that party for that long and be
that successful in your state well
America work specially worked together
right and so being a mayor is all about
getting things done so if you get all
hung up in ideology like we see in the
healthcare debate for instance people at
the local level are not interested in
that we when you take healthcare we need
more health care we're a rich country
eighteen percent of our GDP is spent on
health care Germany spends ten percent
United Kingdom spends eight percent we
need to figure out the cost issue so
that more people have more coverage
that's what people are interested in
they're not interested in political
ideology that's a waste of time in the
main streets of our cities let's get any
worse now not better because well but
but that's right but that's the point is
focusing on that I'm a business guy
entrepreneur to be a good mayor you have
to have the head of a chief executive
officer but the heart of a social worker
it comes together with health care thank
you so much thank you very much have you
here